y'avait pas un conte de serveurs et
l'egypte on les aime beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
on les invite tout le temps heureusement
on adore les habiter au kiel quand ils
sont là c'est bien sûr nos chevaliers du
fiel qui sont avec nous
[Applaudissements]
m
vous allez donc devoir faire dégage donc
si vous tombez sur une noire c'est un
gage une boule noire c'est un gage une
boule jaune
c'est donc une réalité eric et francis
venez tirer une première boule qui
tirent les boules généralement remis à
l'écriture
les amis les chevaliers du ciel organise
commentaires petite boule de neige
les chevaliers du ciel l'eau et d'en
faire les chevaliers du fiel vous
souhaite une bonne année et wayne on n'a
pas ça merci demande à voir attention
c'est lui qui chante les bulls alors à
jaune c'est jour de vérité donc c'est
une vérité vous allez devoir mettre une
note sur 20 ans au physique de l'autre
je connaissais pas alors regarde abattu
mais j med gym et 16 c sur un arbre moi
j'aurais mis 18 à
mais [ __ ] moi je te prépares dans la
catégorie nain jeu mais 19
c'est rsa vous allez faire le sketch de
l'apéro sauf le des rues le début parce
que oui le début mais il verra aussi
vous rapprochez vous achètent ou canton
je me sens pas bien mais quand on fait
un apéro ici on le fait vraiment et vous
devez manger tout le temps alors t'as
pas de femme mais chaque année si j'ai
fait un cadeau l'an dernier
[Rires]
bon ma part je perds mon corps le voyage
toujours et dépôts dépôt des brevets
siens oui christian le dépôt des pots de
christiane mais ce que tu me reçoit à
sympathique je te reçois hockey des jeux
wii fit siala des personnes affirme a
dit ok en resta là sculpteur des jeux
wii fit si honnêtement tu me ramener à
fiera di luca
c est pourquoi tu me dis rien tu le vis
et te dire si je ne sens pas dans ce qui
nous fait vibrer picolant y avait pas un
conte de serveurs
non
apparemment vous dormiez excusez moi
c'est plus fort que moi je veux pas
rester sans rien faire
vous êtes christiane oui de la brigade
des feuilles à châtel je me présente
gibert lavergne l'élève rotofil heures
c'est toi l'aimeront aux fleurs on me
dira peut-être un à leur tour final en
moi je voyais personne a rejeté sur le
qui vive
tenez je vous remets ma convocation je
vous dérange pas au moins tu peux me
tutoyez on est de gauche alors elle est
bien de la convocation
et il ya les deux signatures il ya les
toboggans aussi met au boulot
ouais je déconne tu es prend le tarn en
prenant le temps de nous connaître
parlement de toi comment tu arrivé ici
en bus ça lumineux ça va ça lui faire là
ça va aller fêter le journal et je te
sers comme d'habitude saison après
saison
[Musique]
deux heures tapas les enfants au resto
mais sony d'affairé qui me sont
personnelles et maritimes le vent avoir
rien fait tu vois moi je fais toujours
la main aux rêves je rêve que la la
phrase à tiers seraient employées
municipales tout le pays ne serait qu'un
ballet de blues aux couleurs
multicolores
22h45 l'heure de l'embauché je suis dans
mon casier l'heure du choix posés nous
et verte ou blouson bleu le temps de se
décider midi viennent de sonner
alors c'est que 15 euros trad les
réunions syndicales et il leur de s'y
remettre
alors le soir harassé mais le coeur
léger
nous rentrons dans nos foyers mais tu
pleures petit oui chef
ce monde ne soit qu il un jour et à
lille sera petit alors pour récompenser
notre ténacité nous pourront chanter ce
chant si beau le champ des employés
municipaux feuilles retour à tôt c'est
le chant des municipaux ferrato c'est
bientôt l'heure de l'apéro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]